Bielorrusia no solo es considerada la última
dictadura de Europa y el último país en
el que se aplica de forma efectiva la pena
de muerte en el viejo continente.
También es un país el que un día te puedes
montar tranquilamente en un avión y que de
repente en pleno vuelo el aparato dé la vuelta
para que la FSB, la antigua KGB rusa [sí,
sí, habéis escuchado bien] detenga a empresarios
que no han pasado por el aro.
Todo por obra y gracia del mismísimo Aleksandr
Lukashenko.
Este hombre lleva, ojo, desde 1994 presidiendo
el país. Son ya más de 25 años.
Todo un logro para un candidato “independiente”
que presume de no haber tenido partido político
alguno detrás de él desde 1992.
Y es que, amigos, amigas de VisualPolitik,
el partido es, básicamente... Él mismo.
(La sed de poder de Lukashenko parece infinita.
Este pequeño sátrapa aprendiz y heredero
de los peores mecanismos de control político
de la Unión Soviética no parece que tenga
intención de marcharse. De momento ya anunciado
que se va a presentar a la re-re-re-reelección
en 2020 después de cosechar un éxito arrollador
en las elecciones legislativas de 2019.
Para que os hagáis una idea, de los 110 miembros
de la Cámara de Representantes de Bielorrusia,
la oposición consiguió cero diputados.)
Sí, sí, lo habéis escuchado bien. Cero
diputados. ¿Para qué guardar las apariencias?
El resultado fue 89 diputados independientes
simpatizantes de Lukashenko y 21 diputados
repartidos entre partidos que - oh, sorpresa
- también apoyaban a Lukashenko.
[Vamos, lo que se dice arrasar al más puro
estilo Kim Jong Un]
El caso es que por cosas como esta y también,
claro está,por la represión y la persecución
política, las abducciones, las violaciones
a la libertad de expresión y los derechos
humanos, hay motivos más que de sobra para
considerar a Bielorrusia como una dictadura
con todas las letras.
Una dictadura que tiene unos lazos históricos
estrechísimos con Rusia.
Y no solo hablamos de las similitudes políticas
y de modus operandi del régimen, sino también
de una herencia cultural, histórica y hasta
lingüística común.
Por eso hoy, en este vídeo, os vamos a hablar
del que ha sido todo un curioso romance internacional,
que sin embargo ahora está pasando por su
peor momento.
Bielorrusia y Rusia son como dos novios, eternamente
prometidos y a punto de casarse, que parece
se están arrepintiendo en el último momento.
¿Queréis saber más sobre esta disparatada
historia? Apuesto a que sí.
Atentos.
(LOS VECINOS DE BIELORRUSIA, ENTRE DOS POLOS
OPUESTOS)
Amigos, si hay algo claro en Bielorrusia es
que su situación geopolítica es extremadamente
complicada.
Hablamos de un país encastrado entre dos
poderosos bloques hostiles entre sí: la Unión
Europea y Rusia.
Por un lado, Rusia, la madre Rusia, ha sido
el sustento del país desde su independencia
de la Unión Soviética. Básicamente en la
escena internacional la Bielorrusia de Lukashenko
ha funcionado en la práctica como un Estado
satélite.
Por otro lado, la Unión Europea ha sido durante
muchos años muy dura y crítica con el régimen
por la represión y falta de libertades y
democracia.
Represión que, por ejemplo, explica la desaparición
en 1999 y el 2000 de dos políticos opositores,
un empresario y un periodista, algo que hizo
que la UE impusiera sanciones económicas
y restricciones comerciales al país.
Y es que no, no penséis ni por un segundo
que Lukashenko es un tipo al que le guste
disimular su ramalazo autoritario.
Todo lo contrario. De hecho, incluso le gusta
hacer bromas sobre ello, como esta que hizo
en una entrevista en 2012 para Reuters.
(“Soy el único y último dictador en Europa.
De hecho, no hay ningún otro en ningún lugar
del mundo. [...] Has venido aquí y has visto
a un dictador viviente. ¿Dónde más podrías
ver uno?” - Aleksandr Lukashenko)
[Vamos que eso de ser dictador le gusta más
que a Mourinho ver perder a Guardiola]
Sin embargo frente a todos los pronósticos
y a pesar del fuerte carácter de Lukashenko,
lo cierto es que en los últimos cuatro años
se ha producido una gran mejora de las relaciones
entre Bielorrusia y la Unión Europea.
(Una mejora en las relaciones bilaterales
que, por ejemplo, llevó a que en 2016 la
Unión Europea retirará las sanciones contra
3 empresas y 170 altos cargos o personas cercanas
al régimen. Aún se mantienen otras sanciones,
como por ejemplo el embargo a la venta de
armas, pero fue significativo, una muestra
de a que a pesar de todo las cosas podían
mejorar.
Es decir, que parece que la Unión Europea
se ha puesto las pilas con Bielorrusia en
eso que se ha venido en llamar la Realpolitik,
es decir, la política basada pura y exclusivamente
en intereses prácticos.)
¿Que Bielorrusia es una dictadura? Sí, eso
está claro, pero, amigos…. Llevarse bien
con este país puede ser algo así como meterle
el dedo en el ojo al mismísimo Vladimir Putin.)
Y es que si algo busca en este caso la Unión
Europea es tratar de debilitar el poder y
la influencia de Putin. Y, Bielorrusia es
para el gobierno de Vladimir Putin un país
clave. Su último aliado férreo.
Algo así como ese hijo predilecto al que
protege cueste lo que cueste, pero del que
de vez en cuando también necesita algún
que otro favor.
Por eso a Putin ese tímido pero consiste
acercamiento de la Unión Europea le está
resultando todo un dolor de cabeza.
[Dicho de otra forma, que en la relación
de la Unión Europea con Bielorrusia, lo menos
importante es precisamente Bielorrusia]
(El caso es que durante la última década
el comercio con la Unión Europea ha vuelto
a despegar y sobre todo hay que destacar que
Bielorrusia ha empeza a recibir fondos comunitarios.
Concretamente 110 millones de euros del conocido
como Instrumento Europeo de Vecindad entre
los años 2014 y 2018.)
Sí vale, eso es una minucia en comparación
con lo que a lo largo de los años ha aportado
Rusia, pero muestra una clara mejora en la
relaciones entre Minsk y Bruselas.
Al fin y al cabo en otras circunstancias no
vas por ahí regalando decenas y decenas de
millones de euros.
[Bueno, la verdad es que con la Unión Europea
nunca se sabe]
El caso es que llegados a este punto hay una
pregunta clave:
¿Cómo han sido y cómo están hoy exactamente
las relaciones entre Rusia y Bielorrusia,
dos países hasta ahora hermanos?
Dos países que pocos años después de la
caída de la Unión Soviética llegaron incluso
a estudiar su integración política.
Sí, sí, así.
(Una integración progresiva. Eso fue exactamente
lo que acordaron el propio Lukashenko y el
entonces presidente ruso Boris Yeltsin en
1999. Ese año crearon una estructura supranacional
llamada a integrar poco a poco a los dos estados.
Una estructura con nombre y apellido: el Estado
de la Unión.)
Ahora bien, seguro que a muchos os chirría
la idea de que alguien como Lukashenko, un
tipo con una ambición de poder tan grande,
estuviera dispuesto a integrarse con Rusia,
[lo que evidentemente, no nos engañemos,
le hubiera dado todo el poder a Moscú.]
Entonces, ¿Qué fue lo que llevó a Lukashenko
a pactar esa integración con Boris Yeltsin?
¿Es que acaso pensaba que los rusos le iban
a regalar el poder?
Amigos, para entender la idea de Lukashenko,
la de Rusia, y cómo ha cambiado todo este
tema últimamente, dejad que os expliquemos
en qué consistía todo esto del Estado de
la Unión.
Un proyecto tan disparatado que nació [si
es que en algún momento llegó a nacer] con
heridas fatales.
¡Atentos!
(ESTADO DE LA UNIÓN, LA ABSORCIÓN QUE NUNCA
LLEGA)
Camaradas de VisualPolitik, tal y como os
acabamos de contar hace un momento, esto del
Estado de la Unión se acordó en 1999 entre
Lukashenko y Yeltsin.
Yeltsin no era Putin, ni Lukashenko sabía
tanto de ser un sátrapa como todo lo que
ha aprendido desde entonces.
Pero, ¿qué pretendían realmente Yeltsin
y Lukashenko en el momento en el que se acordó
semejante cosa?
(Por un lado, Rusia buscaba básicamente pegarle
un golpe en la espinilla a la OTAN, que en
esos momentos se acababa de expandir a Polonia,
la República Checa y Hungría.
Expansión que dejaba a las fuerzas del Tratado
del Atlántico Norte prácticamente a las
puertas de Rusia.
Moscú necesitaba un contrapeso fuera como
fuera. Tenía que jugar sus cartas para frenar
el avance de la OTAN y demostrar que seguía
siendo una superpotencia.
Y el contrapeso empezó con su fiel aliado,
hermano de sangre y de ideología, Bielorrusia.)
El caso es que la unión que se planteó creaba
una entidad supranacional en la que poco a
poco ambos países se integrarían en una
especie de bloque político y económico.
Sí, teóricamente ambos países conservarían
su soberanía política y territorial, pero
las decisiones tanto en política económica,
como en política exterior y defensa serían
tomadas por este nuevo órgano. En la práctica
se planteaba una integración muy fuerte.
Y no solo eso, el objetivo de Rusia es que
esta unión fuera mucho más allá y terminara
creando una moneda común, un parlamento único,
una Constitución, tribunales propios, etcétera,
etcétera.
Es decir, crear un megabloque ruso al mejor
estilo de la antigua Unión Soviética.
Sin embargo, amigos pronto aparecieron las
reticencias.
Lo del pacto sonaba muy bien, pero ¿Cómo
repartir el poder? Esa era la pregunta.
Pues veréis, aunque parezca mentira, todo
apunta a que en un primer momento el propio
Lukashenko, ciego de ambición, pensó que
la unión podría convertirlo a él mismo
en el líder plenipotenciario del nuevo megabloque
y de esta forma dirigir no solo los destinos
de Bielorrusia sino también de la propia
Rusia.
Es decir, aunque pueda resultar sorprendente
la jugada que tenía en mente Lukashenko era
algo así como una especie de OPA donde el
pequeño se comía al grande.
[Soñar es gratis.]
El problema, amigos, es que Putin no es Yeltsin
y la Rusia de hoy tampoco se parece mucho
a la Rusia en caída libre de finales de los
años 90.
En otras palabras, al tirano bielorruso el
tiro le salió por la culata.
Lukashenko nunca consiguió sus objetivos
y con el paso de los años al tiempo que Vladimir
Putin afianzaba su poder, Bielorrusia se iba
convirtiendo cada vez más en una economía
aislada de Europa y totalmente dependiente
de Rusia.
[Hasta el punto de que el llamado Estado de
la Unión llegó a significar sólo dos cosas
para Bielorrusia: anexión o chantaje. Fijaos
porque.]
(Durante los últimos 20 años Rusia ha utilizado
la ventas de petróleo y gas natural a precios
por debajo del mercado para consolidar su
influencia en Minsk.
El coste para Rusia de esta política ha sido
elevado, algunos cálculos, como los del Ministro
de Finanzas ruso, Anton Siluanov apuntan a
más de 2.000 millones de dólares.)
Y ojo a la jugada. Durante este tiempo Lukashenko
ha estado haciendo negocio año a año. La
economía bielorrusa se ha especializado en
la transformación petrolera, en las refinerías,
y en la exportación de combustibles.
De esta forma a medida que las negociaciones
para lograr el Estado de la Unión se congelaban,
Lukashenko seguía sacando partido a los acuerdos
vigentes.
Y claro, como os podéis imaginar, llegó
un punto en que Rusia se cansó de esperar
sin recibir nada a cambio. En cierto modo
Vladimir Putin sintió que los bielorrusos
le estaban tomando el pelo.
Y, amigos, no no no. Con Putin no se juega.
En 2019 Moscú empezó a condicionar los contratos
petroleros a los progresos en la construcción
del Estado de la Unión. Es decir, sin avances
no habrá más petróleo ruso. [Vamos que
Putin le dijo algo así como: Ándate con
ojo, Luka, que o te portas bien o te quito
el zumito de dinosaurio… Tú verás]
(Rusia insinúa a Bielorrusia que se una en
un estado unificado a cambio de un acuerdo
petrolero: Lukashenko - Reuters)
Y amigos es justo aquí cuando se desató
la crisis, una lucha a cara de perro entre
los dos líderes.
Atentos.
(EL GRAN GIRO: ¿TRAICIÓN O LUCHA POR EXISTIR?)
Hasta el pasado año 2019, Lukashenko decía
una y otra vez cosas como esta:
(“Ambos podríamos unirnos mañana, sin
problemas”)
Sin embargo, a comienzos de 2020, la retórica
ha cambiado bastante. Fijaos.
(“Tenemos nuestro propio país, somos soberanos
e independientes. [...] Y no podemos ser parte
de otro país. [...] No puedo traicionaros
y disolver Bielorrusia, incluso en nuestra
hermana Rusia. [...] Si llego a acordar eso,
los bielorrusos me comerían vivo en un año.
[...] Es honorable ser el primer presidente,
y estoy seguro de que no quiero ser el último.”
- Aleksandr Lukashenko)
Es como si de repente hubiese despertado en
Lukashenko un espíritu nacionalista y soberanista
que antes no existía.
Ahora bien, ¿realmente va en serio o es simplemente
una estrategia de presión para sacarle más
y más concesiones a Moscú, a sabiendas de
que quizás Putin necesita a Bielorrusia para
perpetuarse en el poder?
Un momento, ¿Que Putin puede necesitar a
su vecino para mantenerse en el poder?
Pues sí, lo habéis escuchado bien.
Actualmente el presidente ruso está desarrollando
varios planes para mantenerse en el poder
más allá del 2024, y uno de esos planes
podría pasar precisamente por Bielorrusia.
(La estrategia sería la siguiente.
Si Rusia y Bielorrusia terminan de crear un
nuevo Estado, un nuevo ente de gobierno diferente
al de la Federación Rusa, que englobe a ambos
países, Putin podría ser presidente de ese
nuevo Estado ya que estaría sujeto a una
nueva Constitución, con unas nuevas condiciones
y con un nuevo estatus de poder.
Es decir, Putin volvería a ser presidente
pero no de la Federación Rusa, sino del Estado
de la Unión de Rusia y Bielorrusia.)
Sea como sea, parece que la disputa va en
serio,
(En enero las exportaciones de petróleo de
Rusia a Bielorrusia se desplomaron un 75%
respecto a lo previsto. Rusia redujo las entregas
en un millón y medio de toneladas.)
Y ya os hemos dicho que en la economía bielorrusa
la industria petroquímica tiene mucha importancia.
Así que esto ha obligado a Lukashenko a elegir
entre dos caminos:
O rendirse a Moscú, o tratar de encontrar
otros amigos que le suministren todo el combustible
que necesita para que el país no se venga
abajo.
Y ahí, ahí es donde han aparecido nuevos
amigos. Fijaos.
(Bielorrusia comienza a importar petróleo
de Noruega tras la interrupción rusa - Business
Insider)
Pero no solo se trata de Noruega. Minsk ha
encontrado de repente a otro salvador. Un
país que lleva diez años sin mediar palabra
diplomáticamente con Bielorrusia y que ahora,
de repente, quiere restablecer al 100% las
relaciones diplomáticas. ¿Alguna idea?
Atentos.
(Pompeo visita Bielorrusia mientras los lazos
de Minsk con Moscú se desgastan - Reuters
“Estados Unidos quiere ayudar a Bielorrusia
a construir su propio país soberano. Nuestros
productores están 100% listos para proporcionar
todo el petróleo que necesitéis a precios
competitivos. Vuestra nación no debería
verse forzada a depender de ningún socio
para tener prosperidad o seguridad.” - Mike
Pompeo, Secretario de Estado de Estados Unidos)
[No digáis que no es un buena jugada.]
Sin embargo, lo cierto es que a pesar de conseguir
nuevos proveedores, hoy por hoy Bielorrusia
está sufriendo una acuciante escasez de petróleo
que ya ha provocado la suspensión de las
exportaciones petroquímicas.
Exportaciones que el país necesita para obtener
divisas, dólares.
Y eso es lo que ha llevado al dictador bielorruso
a hacer uso de su penúltima bala: amenazar
con robarle a Rusia parte de sus exportaciones
de crudo, aprovechando que el oleoducto Druzhba
por el que Rusia exporta petróleo a Europa
pasa precisamente por su territorio.
La última bala sería robárselo.
(Bielorrusia amenaza con sacar petróleo ruso
con destino a Europa - Al Jazeera)
Sea como sea, tal y como veis, las relaciones
entre Putin y Lukashenko están que arden.
Al borde de bloquearse mutuamente en el WhatsApp.
El presidente bielorruso se está empezando
a arrimar a Occidente para evitar que su aislamiento
propicie una temida invasión rusa al estilo
de Crimea, y que eso les pille solos en el
mundo y sin nadie que les defienda. [Bueno,
sin nadie que le defienda a él y a su sillón].
Y desde luego ya os podéis imaginar que eso
de amenazar con robar el petróleo ruso en
Moscú no ha tenido que sentar nada pero que
nada bien. ¿Os imagináis la cara de Putin
si su petróleo empezara a desaparecer de
los oleoductos?
[¿Sí? ¿Vladi? Sí, soy Luka, dime dime.
¡No puede ser verdad! ¿Cómo que no ha llegado
el petróleo? ¿Pues chico, aquí no hemos
visto nada eh? Mira, tú no te preocupes que
si yo veo algo te digo]
En fin, así están las cosas en la que supone
la última batalla del loco escenario de Europa
del Este. En VisualPolitik estaremos atentos
a cómo puedan desarrollarse los acontecimientos.
Mientras tanto, ¿Tú que piensas? ¿Se ha
ganado Rusia el derecho a controlar a su vecino
por todo el petróleo que le han entregado
en condiciones preferentes? ¿Conseguirá
el presidente ruso salirse con la suya y anexionarse
al país vecino? ¿Realmente Lukashenko está
dispuesto a girar hacia Occidente?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
ya sabéis si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle al botón de
like.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.